première semaine marathon
jean castex le nouveau pensionnaire de
matignon s'est démultiplié ces derniers
jours dans l'immédiat dans les
institutions nationales et sur le
terrain pour faire connaître son nom et
son visage
jusque là inconnu à l'assemblée
nationale le premier ministre a confirmé
son souhait de maintenir un rythme
soutenu sur les réformes
les retraites la dépendance l'assurance
chômage
le plan de relance tout sera mis sur la
table
nous allons écouter et concertée une
première intervention dans l'hémicycle
qui ne fut pas des plus faciles danser
pour la lenteur de ses interventions par
l'opposition
le stic jean castex puis débat c'est
assez pénible à supporter les mots
pouces entre les arbres et les arbres
entre les mots il est là il parle à deux
à l'heure pour dire des banalités
alors soit on prend mal et on dit mais
il se moque de nous soit on se dit c'est
le maximum dont il est capable
ce n'est pas un bon moment de démocratie
parlementaire à écouter le premier
ministre ce matin à la séance de
questions au gouvernement
je constate qu'il a pour mission de nous
endormir si le premier dossier
concernant la hausse des rémunérations
des personnels de santé semble se
terminer
un autre dossier beaucoup plus explosif
attend l'ancien conseiller de nicolas
sarkozy la réforme des retraites
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que l'ensemble des syndicats de salariés
et une fois n'est pas coutume le medef
ont une opinion bien arrêtée sur le
sujet on a dit très clairement au
premier ministre que la question des
retraites ne devait pas venir polluer la
question de la relance économique et
sociale et la question de la
préservation
le régime universel de retraite par
points notre position n'a pas changé
nous n'en voulons pas quand tous les
syndicats et même les patrons sont
d'accord pour dire ce sujet là il est
pas prioritaire
quand on dit qu'on est à l'écouté qu'on
veut dialoguer c'est évident que on en
tient compte
la priorité c'est le plan de relance se
précipitaient cet été pour renégocier
sur ce sujet anxiogène n'est pas une
bonne idée
un premier couac pour celui qui
souhaitait remettre à plat un certain
nombre de sujets de l'assurance chômage
au plan de relance déjà mis sous
pression par les syndicats le premier
ministre aura bien besoin de ses talents
de négociateur et pour ne pas voir la
marmite sociale française explosé de
nouveaux bons jours